gone
foreign
wow
uh
uh
so
waiting
there he is
all right
all right good afternoon sorry we're a
little late we've got voting going on
um and uh let me
uh read we're talking about nominations
and i want to thank senator klobuchar
and senator menendez for being here
today i had a productive discussion
with secretary secretary of state
designate tony blinken
and director of national intelligence
designate of real
haines we had a wide-ranging discussion
that covered the globe and priorities
for the u.s
foreign policy national security in
particular i
urge the incoming biden administration
to be tough on china
but in a smarter more multilateral way
than the trump administration was
what was immediately clear in our
discussion is that president-elect
biden's
foreign policy and national security
team are exceptionally qualified
accomplished individuals with the
expertise
to protect our nation and advance
american interests abroad
in addition to tony blinken in april of
real haines
she
president-elect biden continues to roll
out an impressive slate of nominees to
his cabinet
and other key administrative positions
now after all we went through over the
past four years
i would expect that almost all of
president-elect biden's nominees would
be widely acceptable to the senate
after all republican senators looked the
other way and confirmed several of
donald trump's unqualified
ethically compromised and
scandal-plagued appointees
republicans argued that a president
deserves broad deference when it comes
to the cabinet
and official appointments well
republicans ought to give
president-elect biden
the same deference but we're already
seeing more pearl clutching
about overblown complaints from
republican senators
who conveniently ignored scandal after
scandal
in the trump administration honestly the
hypocrisy is astounding
after spending four years pretending
they didn't see the
see the latest insane tweet from
president trump
republican senators have just found the
passwords to their twitter accounts
since they're now suddenly concerned
about what's being said about them on
twitter
but after the caliber of nominees that
this republican majority confirmed over
the past four years it would be
impossible
impossible to take them seriously the
senate committee should prepare to hold
hearings on president-elect biden's
nominees in january
immediately after the georgia elections
that's what the senate did for president
trump and for president obama
that's what the senate must do for
president-elect biden as well
our nation's facing unprecedented crises
we need the next administration to hit
the ground running to tackle these
multiple challenges
that means ensuring that on january 21st
2020 january 20th 2021
president joe biden and vice president
kamala harris have much of their team in
place
i hope i hope my republican colleagues
will look at joe biden's nominees based
on their merits
and their impressive credentials and not
let petty political animus get in the
way
senator menendez
well thank you mr leader look i want to
echo particularly in the national
security front uh the leader's comments
this is about our nation's security and
prosperity it shouldn't be about policy
there's no question that the slave
nominees particularly
in the state department u.n ambassador
and elsewhere put forward by the
president-elect are capable
and qualified now does the senate have
to do its due diligence and vet them of
course
uh do we have to understand their
thinking and ask them about their views
of course
that's part of advice and consent but
there's a difference between that
and some who are already suggesting
that they seek to weaponize the
confirmation process and seek to turn it
into a political wrecking ball those who
ultimately for their own purposes uh
as they may aspire for future elect
future election to the presidency of the
united states
wants to use the vetting process in a
way
that undermines the very essence of what
we need our nation to be able to do on
day one
is that the american people deserve to
have a government
now that only looks like america but
that is up and running
from day one to deal with the pandemic
and the economic wreckage
that has come from the pandemic and to
pursue our interests and extend our
values around the globe today
i was on a panel with european
parliamentarians
and the cry from all and these are all
people from the european union elected
different countries
different political beliefs and whatnot
but the one thing they want to see
is america be back and engaged in the
world
that takes a secretary of state tony
blinken
is an incredibly qualified individual to
help us once again
be back on the global stage engage
creating more allies less enemies
creating more prosperity less challenges
and that also takes
a un ambassador and ambassador
greenfield is an extraordinary
i know her i helped her become the
assistant secretary of state
for africa when i was the chair of the
committee she's an exceptional example
of an exceptional career
diplomat that's who we need helping lead
the national security of the united
states that's what we need to get on day
one which means we need early hearings
in january and a vote in order to
guarantee it
senator klobuchar thank you very much um
and thank you for your leadership
senator schumer at this critical time
and thank you senator menendez
um i think that really president elect
biden has set the tone here when he said
uh this should not be a partisan moment
this should be an american moment
and we just don't have time to mess
around
we have as bob has pointed out of
security
threats across the country we've got
across the world we've got
incredibly qualified nominees which
really are in keeping with the tone
that the president-elect said from the
minute uh the president
would not uh concede this election um
president-elect biden
took the stage and said you know what
give me a chance
people that voted for donald trump and
i'll give you a chance he set that tone
and now you see that tone in these
nominees
in people like tony blinken and people
like someone who won't
come before us for confirmation but i
must mention because he's from minnesota
and used to work for me jake sullivan
you see people that are well respected
um
including um uh treasury secretary to be
yellen um and so he has really lived his
words in who he has nominated and it's
our job to get it done
and the last thing i would add is that
we are in the middle
of a pandemic right now i don't have to
tell you that
and one of the things that we need right
now
is stability for the rest of the world
and for our own country
and i am been pleased that my colleagues
are moving
ahead with some bipartisan negotiations
obviously that's not done
uh we know we haven't heard good words
from uh leader mcconnell on this but
that doesn't mean that we cannot keep
moving ahead because
we cannot have no leadership for america
in place
when we want to lead the world when it
comes to this vaccine
that's going to mean funding to get this
vaccine out if i said at home you just
can't drop a bunch of vaccines
in the middle of la verne minnesota and
think they're just going to magically
show up there it takes coordination on
infrastructure
on storage and the like and to do that
we need joe biden to be able to put a
leadership team
both internationally and domestically so
i'm excited to
work on this i think we have
had great nominees come forward and it
is on our republican leaders and
us to work together to get them
confirmed immediately
thank you senator klobuchar yes
yes ma'am i have two questions you sent
a proposal
to leader mcconnell on covid relief last
night what was in it and are you let
going of the two trillion dollar demand
that you previously had
and also i'd like you to respond to
attorney general bill barr saying there
was no white friend fraud
please well in in response to attorney
general bill barr
i guess he's the next one to be fired
since he now too
says there's no fraud trump seems to
fire anyone
in that regard in the first uh leader uh
speaker pelosi and i sent
yesterday a proposal uh to uh leader
mcconnell in an effort to get things
moving
i'm not going to get into the details it
was a private proposal to help us
uh move the ball forward but let's make
no mistake about it i just heard leader
mcconnell say
he's going to put another partisan
proposal on the floor he's going to talk
to mccarthy and trump and put something
on the floor
the obvious fact of the matter is the
biggest
impediment to getting in agreement
is the republican leader refusing to
negotiate in a bipartisan way
he knows darn well the house is
democratic majority he knows darn well
he needs democratic votes in the senate
to get anything done since a number of
his people won't vote for any proposal
and yet he continues to negotiate in a
partisan way
uh speaker pelosi and i sent him the
proposal in a good faith effort
to start to get him to negotiate in a
bipartisan way i always welcome
and encourage my democratic members to
talk to republican members and there's
another proposal
that way all are in efforts to get
leader mcconnell
to stop being so partisan because the
needs
of people are desperate desperate
desperate
during this christmas season and later
he indicated that he wants to add it to
the must-pass government funding bill
are you worried about getting jammed and
that you've lost your negotiating power
and you're going to have to accept
whatever he comes up with
let me just say i hope mcconnell will
start doing things in a
bipartisan way every time he's tried to
do it in a partisan way it has failed
um
about holding committee chairmanships
and leadership positions
how do you plan to succeed as leader on
this issue
look i think the bottom line is every
two years we have a robust discussion in
our caucus about the caucus rules and
what should be changed and what
shouldn't be changed and we're going to
have another good discussion in the next
few weeks
this morning there was a 900 billion
bipartisan proposal
uh proposed uh what do you think of that
typically does your
letter more than that or around again
our letter was done in a private way to
get mcconnell and maybe the white house
to move
um so i'm not going to get into its
details
the bottom line is that it's an effort
to
get things moving forward as for the
proposal
that uh the bipartisan group of senators
announced as i said i've always
encouraged our democratic senators to
sit down with republican senators
and negotiate and this is a very this is
a good effort i haven't seen all the
details they haven't come out with the
details yet
but when democrats and republicans can
get together that's a good thing
and i hope leader mcconnell will heed
that call
yes so we're assuming by this that lisa
mcconnell hasn't
we hope they will give us a real
response so we can get something done
next question yep go ahead
let's hope he'll negotiate in a
bipartisan way thus far
every time he's done it in a partisan
way it hasn't worked
there's a democratic house they need
democratic votes in the senate
i know that you've said you encourage
your members to meet with
republicans but this proposal they've
put forward is a full
trillion dollars less than what you are
proposing so is it something that you
all
think look we have to see the details
bipartisan proposals
again on what is needed to get things
done
i just um one thing i note about the
earlier question
about mcconnell and whether he'll jam us
and those things
i do remember there were republicans in
that group right
and uh while it is not nearly what we
had asked for there were republicans
that stood up and said they wanted
this amount of money so i don't wouldn't
assume that everyone's just going to go
down the path with mitch mcconnell this
time
when you have states like in maine that
have had so many small businesses close
um there was a yelp study out recently
that showed 800 small businesses are
closing a day
we have restaurants that have tried to
hang in and can't do it anymore
we've got a vaccine around the corner
light at the end of the tunnel
but if we don't put the funding into it
uh to get the distribution going and the
storage going we're not going to be able
to recover like we want to
we've got the head of the federal
reserve under donald trump his
appointment
jerome powell saying it would be a
tragedy if we didn't get something done
so i wouldn't just assume that
everyone's going to go down his path
this time and i think that this
bipartisan negotiation
well of course just a start and uh is
significant
uh to show that some people are willing
to cross over to get something done
which senator schumer has been calling
for from the beginning
okay last one joe biden said that on his
first day of office he will give
transgender students access to sports
bathrooms and locker rooms in accordance
with their gender identity in all
federally funded schools
do you think he has the ability to do
this and do you agree with this decision
i agree with the decision and i know
he'll check things out thoroughly
legally
thank you everybody
sorry